[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 Rosa Pérez mateu conmigo en
el estudio Rosa vamos a ver entonces las
portadas internacionales que destacan
los seis meses que cumple hoy la
invasión rusa en Ucrania eso es Raúl y
bueno recordemos a que cuando empezó
esta invasión el propio 24 de febrero de
este mismo año fue un tema que
protagonizó las portadas de alrededor
del mundo tras muchos meses de
incertidumbres sobre si se iba a dar o
no está invasión rusa de Ucrania gran
escala empecemos entonces con
exactamente este medio escocés dice día
de la independencia de Ucrania así lo
titula y señala que Ucrania celebra este
Día Nacional con humor prudencia y
resistencia ante las amenazas rusas
Bueno vamos ahora con liberación de
Francia que dice seis meses de conflicto
en Ucrania la vida en guerra y entre
distintos ángulos en los que aborda este
especial dedicado tres meses de
conflicto señala el imposible balance
humano no de esta guerra porque todavía
no se puede acceder a muchas zonas y no
se pueden contabilizar el número de
víctimas mortales Pues que realmente han
tenido lugar desde finales de febrero
seguimos viendo portadas europeas esta
vez con el País España Rosa Exacto que
destaca un poco las consecuencias sobre
la Unión Europea de este conflicto dice
Europa se asoma la recesión tras seis
meses de guerra Y es que recordemos que
además del impacto sobre la seguridad
alimentaria en la norte de África y
también en el medio oriente esta guerra
tiene importantes consecuencias para lo
que es la seguridad energética sobre
todo en la Unión Europea no tal y como
señala el país dice la Unión Europea
está afectada por el aumento del precio
del gas y la estabilidad del suministro
el euro está en mínimos las autoridades
alemanas preven una inflación de dos
dígitos pero a pesar de esto Estados
Unidos y Europa animan a kiev recuperar
la Península de crimea un giro reciente
de los acontecimientos no dice el país
la invasión de Ucrania gran escala
cumple seis meses pero en realidad
empezó hace 8 años cuando Rusia se
aneccionó crimea por otro lado dice que
kiev se ha propuesto como decíamos
recuperar esta propuesta del manejo pero
citan a selensky diciendo que Esto
empezó en crimea y acabará en crimea una
afirmación que fue aplaudida ayer por
vonderleyen por Anthony blinken y por
representantes de unos 60 países sin
embargo recordemos que tanto sebastopol
como crimea fue fueron anexionados a
Rusia tras un referendo que fue muy
cuestionado no fue reconocido por la
comunidad internacional pero contó con
una alta participación en ambos casos
una participación mayor al 80% y de las
personas que votaron más de un 95% en
ambos casos votaron a favor de
digamos unirse a la federación rusa
vamos ahora al continente americano
vamos a Estados Unidos con el New York
Times Exacto porque este medio
estadounidense titula en la Guerra de
Ucrania una planta nuclear capturada
como rehén con esta imagen satélite de
la central nuclear de saporiya
recordemos la masa grande de Europa y
también destaca los trabajadores
intentan evitar el desastre bajo la
mirada de los francotiradores y en
América del Sur vamos con el espectador
de Colombia Rosa Exacto que destaca sin
Vientos de paz y señala que pues no se
ve que Próximamente se pueda dar salida
este conflicto de forma diplomática
incluso señala este medio colombiano que
el asesinato de daria dugging
de la filósofo ruso Alexander duguin
hace temer que se intensifique la guerra
en todo caso en la imagen de este
funeral le daría duguinal hemos visto en
muchas portadas como veíamos también en
la portada del español el país vamos
ahora a la esa rusa que destacana Rosa
sputnite o cromersante Pues básicamente
lo que encontramos de forma muy
destacada en Muchos medios de
comunicación de Rusia son las
declaraciones del ministro de defensa
serguéi la desaceleración de la
operación de Moscú en Ucrania es una
decisión consciente para minimizar bajas
civiles en todo caso sea consciente uno
es cierto que la mayoría de la del mundo
cuando empezó esta guerra es la podía
prever como una Guerra Relámpago no una
guerra que va a terminar rápidamente y
en todo caso Claro está que no ha sido
así continuamos con cierta incertidumbre
seis meses después de que empezar esta
invasión bueno Rosa vamos ahora al que
esposa y a la Ucrania que destacan en
las lo que pasa no con las pérdidas
contabilizadas del ejército ruso
exactamente estos medios de comunicación
como otros en su cabecera tienen unos
dibujos con los que van a contabilizando
y unas cifras cito literal Horizonte una
estimación de las pérdidas del enemigo y
ahí van actualizando estos datos
diariamente en estos momentos vemos en
ambos medios que contabilizan que Rusia
ha perdido unos
45.700 soldados de los cuales unos a mil
estarían prisioneros cautivos en Ucrania
y que habría perdido Moscú también unos
2000 tanques o unos 15 buques también en
ambos medios de comunicación encontramos
artículos digamos de digamos en
enaltecimiento del nacionalismo
ucraniano tras 31 años de Independencia
Dicen esta es la etapa final para
consolidarse como estado también
encontramos este tipo de artículo en el
kiev independen que titula su editorial
el día de la independencia que dijeron
que nunca celebraríamos y Déjame leer un
párrafo dice Hace seis meses la segunda
potencia militar más fuerte del mundo
atacó a Ucrania por todos lados los
medios occidentales hablaban de cuando
caería kiev no caería o no era David
contra Goliat y el mundo no esperaba un
milagro por eso es tan importante que
seis meses después podamos conmemorar el
día de la Independencia y dicen que
apoyar a Ucrania no es caridad sino una
necesidad para todo el mundo occidental
y que nosotros quede por fuera las fotos
que resalta el medio algeciras Exacto
este medio hace un recopilatorio de
algunas de las imágenes más destacadas
de estos seis meses de Invasión rusa de
Ucrania veíamos esta primera no una
madre con su hijo huyendo de kiev el
mismo 24 de febrero también recordemos
algunas imágenes que dieron la vuelta al
mundo como la evacuación de la
maternidad de mariupol en marzo la
evacuación de civiles en la devastación
en bucha y es una serie que termina
precisamente con una imagen del 20 de
agosto de este 2022 Hace cuatro días en
que precisamente se ve gente paseando
por el centro de kiev observando tanques
rusos destruidos y traídos a la capital
ucraniana ampliamos esta información
rosa con nuestro primer invitado al día
gracias